so long this summer let's join viscose
New York phila- editor and co-founder of
vagina events from David Wells summoned
David thanks so much for joining us this
afternoon mendham I guess it's safe to
say truly politics free super bowl and
last night but there was a lot of
concern ahead of it I'll absolutely i
think a lot of folks expected a more
overt statement from lady gaga it seems
like the the president of put his cell
phone down so it wasn't too many tweets
from him last night but there's plenty
on a lot of people's minds and i think
that's why the super bowl is probably a
little lighter than most people expected
because i think that kitten probably
needed a little escape from politics but
there certainly it's on everyone's mind
the travel ban you know Russia you've
seen the bill o'reilly interview with
Trump sort of pretty much equating
America with Russia and is there some
trouble there but i think that uh you
know it was a lighter super bowl because
i think they really wanted to sort of
lift spirits but the commercials as you
mentioned in your piece i think we're
really interesting Budweiser had a
commercial Airbnb had a commercial that
talked about accepting everyone so there
was some subtle protest there and it was
represented even in some of the
advertisement i mean do you think the
Budweiser ad was actually in protest
them to Donald Trump's immigration
brannamon they argued that actually they
planned this advert for months amend
obviously the biggest most watched TV
event of the year in America so they
said they've been planning this per
month do you think it was really a
comment towards and Donald Thompson
recent policy I don't think it was
completely coincidental I mean you got
to keep in mind you've been president
for two for about two or three weeks but
this is the rhetoric that we've been
hearing from his side for months now now
so I think but wiser you know they do a
lot of consumer sort of testing and add
testing and so I think that they knew
that this was hit a chord with the
American people okay let's take a look
at Donald Trump's response from
discharge in Seattle actually puller for
the holes on that travel ban I guess
before we actually watched the superbawl
he said I've instructed home and secure
he to check people coming into our
country very carefully the courts are
making the job very difficult now he was
also added that he anything bad that
happens he's going to blame those judges
what are you thoughts on that well again
this is there the administration sort of
attempt to you know look we have three
branches of government and I think this
is one of the checks and checks and
balances that the founders of this
country intended to sort of take place
and I think what you find out is that
the truck administration like they have
done with the media they are trying to
undermine this this branch of government
and I think that we are heading for
constitutional showdown but it's
unfortunate that this president doesn't
have a respect for law that he believes
that he is a dictator that his way
should go and that there should be no
opposition you know and you're seeing
that and what's so troubling about that
is you're seeing out really aggressively
not just with this judge but you're also
seeing that with the media you know his
top advisors Steve of the abandoned
called the media the opposition party so
you're seeing this with anyone who sort
of a stands up the trunk you see a real
country concerted effort to try to
illegitimate them and take them out but
he is president of the United States
he's voted for and by by your people do
you think it's right that judges should
undermine or all undermining the present
in this way well he was he was elected
through the Electoral College you gotta
remember that he did not win the popular
goalie as a matter of fact he's three
million short three million votes short
of what hillary clinton i had so i think
that there is a over reaching on his
part he does not have a majority he does
not have a mandate and rabbit and try to
do something that's a little bit more
inclusive he's actually sort of actually
you know then even more extreme that i
think most people believe that he would
be in its first uh you know two weeks or
three weeks of his presidency and we
also getting these tales actually
families being reunited while this them
temporary hold on that ban is being put
in place to me what sort of
respects do you think we could see
happening here while indeed Donald Trump
is waiting for employers and to respond
to should get that response later on and
this afternoon but in the meantime
people now coming together who initially
originally weren't able to get into the
country absolutely you know you see that
but i think the long-term negative
effects of this will be that you're
giving those who already have a negative
view of the united states and many of
them you know justifiably so you're
giving them even more fodder you you're
saying that the United States does have
a war against Islam and so you you're
only involving your enemies those who do
to seek to do america american farm and
i don't think this administration never
really gets this conservatives don't
really get this is that terrorism is is
is is my deal and it's a reaction
oftentimes for some some of the policies
that the united states has put in place
and this this band only goes to affirm
what some of them may see as America
America's aggression towards their
religion in our culture ok so the Wilson
really good talking to you thanks much
to join us from Sky News this afternoon
thank you